foreign
good afternoon everyone
my name is Dr Miller and the SCP we're
going to be looking at today is scp-106
object class
ketter
special containment procedures
revision 11 6.
no physical interaction with scp-106 is
allowed at any time all physical
interaction must be approved by no less
than a two-thirds vote from o5 command
and may only extend to testing
situations all staff research security
class D Etc are to remain at least 20
meters away from the containment cell at
all times except for mandated
maintenance and re-evaluation checks
containment cell must be held suspended
in a secondary cell the walls of which
must be at least 30 meters distant from
the outer walls of the first or primary
cell the secondary cell is to remain
under total observation at all times and
be both illuminated and clear of any and
all debris any items movement or
non-normal activity noted within the
secondary cell will result in a full
site lockdown lockdown will be
maintained until a situation normal
dispatch is issued by sight command
any corrosion observed on the primary
cell secondary cell staff members or
other site locations within 200 meters
of scp-106 are to be reported to site
security immediately any objects or
Personnel lost to scp-106 are to be
deemed missing or killed in action no
recovery attempts are to be made under
any circumstances
note
scp-106 does not have a docile State and
a reduction in activity or increased
compliance from scp-106 is to be deemed
a luring tactic immediately preceding an
aggressive action and treated as such
note SCP discontinued due to escape
percentage
revision 11 7. no physical interaction
with scp-106 is allowed at any time all
physical interaction must be approved by
no less than a two-thirds vote from o5
command and may only extend to testing
situations all staff research security
class D Etc are to remain at least 30
meters away from the containment cell at
all times except under direct order from
site command
scp-106 is to be kept within a sealed
container comprised of 16 layers of
lead-lined Steel each separated by no
less than 18 centimeters of open space
aside from minimal support struts said
container is to be kept suspended by a
continuous current system within a fluid
medium this medium is to be replaced in
48-hour cycles and constantly monitored
for any corrosion intrusion
any corrosion observed on any
containment cell surfaces staff members
or other site locations within 200
meters of scp-106 are to be reported to
site security immediately any objects or
Personnel lost to scp-106 are to be
deemed missing or killed in action no
recovery attempts are to be made under
any circumstances
scp-106 does not have a docile State any
reduction in activity or increased
compliance from scp-106 is to be deemed
a luring tactic immediately preceding in
aggressive action and treated as such
note observation of scp-106 has shown
slight resistance when passing through
lead or other similar Metals the
thickness of the material appears to
make no difference in addition multiple
layers of thin material appear to slow
scp-106 forcing it to enter and
re-emerge multiple times fluids also
appear to temporarily confuse scp-106
note SCP discontinued due to multiple
surface breaches agitation system
continued to disperse corrosion during
breach event resulting in multiple
breaches and full containment failure
revision 11 8.
no physical interaction with scp-106 is
allowed at any time all physical
interaction must be approved by no less
than a two-thirds vote from o5 command
any such interaction must be undertaken
in ar2 maximum security sites after a
general non-essential staff evacuation
all staff research security class D Etc
are to remain at least 60 meters away
from the containment cell at all times
except in the event of breach events
scp-106 is to be contained in a sealed
container comprised of lead-lined Steel
the container will be sealed within 40
layers of identical material each layer
separated by no less than 36 centimeters
of empty space support struts between
layers are to be randomly spaced
containers to remain suspended no less
than 60 centimeters from any Surface by
ELO IID electromagnetic supports
secondary containment area is to be
comprised of 16 spherical cells each
filled with various fluids and a random
assembly of surfaces and supports
secondary containment is to be fitted
with light systems capable of flooding
the entire assembly with no less than 80
000 lumens of light instantly with no
direct human involvement both
containment areas are to remain under 24
hours surveillance
any corrosion observed on any
containment cell surfaces staff members
or other site locations within 200
meters of scp-106 are to be reported to
site security immediately any objects or
Personnel lost to scp-106 are to be
deemed missing or killed in action no
recovery attempts are to be made under
any circumstances
note continued research and observation
have shown that when faced with highly
complex or random Assemblies of
structures
scp-106 can be confused showing a marked
delay on entry and exit from said
structure scp-106 has also shown an
aversion to direct sudden light this is
not manifested in any form of physical
damage but a rapid exit into the pocket
Dimension generated On Solid Surfaces
these observations along with those of
lead aversion and liquid confusion have
reduced the general Escape incidents by
43 percent the primary cells have also
been effective in recovery incidents
requiring recall protocol
observation is ongoing
description
scp-106 appears to be an elderly
humanoid with a general appearance of
advanced decomposition this appearance
may vary but the rotting quality is
observed in all forms scp-106 is not
exceptionally agile and will remain
motionless for days at a time waiting
for prey scp-106 is also capable of
scaling any vertical surface and can
remain suspended upside down
indefinitely when attacking scp-106 will
attempt to incapacitate prey by damaging
major organs muscle groups or tendons
then pull disabled prey into its pocket
Dimension scp-106 appears to prefer
human prey items in the 10 to 25 years
of age bracket
scp-106 causes a corrosion effect in all
solid matter it touches engaging a
physical breakdown in materials several
seconds after contact this is observed
as rusting rotting and cracking of
materials and the creation of a black
mucus-like substance similar to the
material coning scp-106 this effect is
particularly detrimental to living
tissues and is assumed to be a
pre-digestion action corrosion continues
for six hours after contact after which
the effect appears to burn out
scp-106 is capable of passing through
solid matter leaving behind a large
patch of its corrosive mucus scp-106 is
able to vanish inside solid matter
entering what is assumed to be a form of
pocket Dimension scp-106 is then able to
exit this Dimension from any point
connected to the initial entry point
examples entering the inner wall of a
room and exiting the outer wall entering
a wall and exiting from the ceiling it
is unknown if this is the point of
origin for scp-106 or a simple layer
created by a cp106
limited observation of this pocket
Dimension has shown it to be comprised
mostly of halls and rooms with entry
this activity can continue for days with
some subjected individuals being
released for the express purpose of
hunting recapture and
addendum
SCP review notes
due to the exceedingly difficult to
contain nature of scp-106 SCP is to be
reviewed every three months or during a
post-breach incident physical restraints
are impossible and direct physical
damage appears to have no effect on
scp-106 current SCP has a revolves
around basic observation and immediate
response previous more proactive special
containment procedures have been
recalled due to the events of preaching
and
notes on Behavior
scp-106 appears to go through long
periods of dormancy in which it will
remain completely motionless for up to
three months the cause for this is
unknown however it has been shown that
this appears to be used as a lulling
tactic
scp-106 will emerge from this state in a
very agitated State and will attack and
abduct staff and cause gross damage to
its containment cell and the site at
large recall protocol
scp-106 appears to hunt an attack based
on desire not hunger scp-106 will attack
and collect multiple prey items during a
hunting Behavior event keeping many
alive in the pocket dimension for
extended periods of time
scp-106 has no determinable limit and
appears to collect a random number of
prey items during an event
the inner Dimension accessed by scp-106
appears to be only accessible by scp-106
recording and transmission devices have
been shown to still operate inside this
Dimension though recordings and
Transmissions are very degraded it
appears that scp-106 will play with
captured prey and appears to have full
control of time space and perception
inside this Dimension scp-106 appears
recall protocol
in the event of a breach event by
scp-106 a human within the 10 to 25
years of age bracket will be prepped for
recall with the compromise containment
cell being replaced and restored for use
when the cell is ready the lure subject
will be injured preferably via the
breakage of a long bone such as the
femur or the severing of a major tendon
such as the Achilles tendon lower
subject will then be placed in the
prepped cell and the sound emitted by
said subject will be transmitted over
the site public address system
scp-106 will typically begin to
gravitate toward the lure subject within
10 to 15 minutes after hearing the
subject should scp-106 not respond to
the initial broadcast additional
physical trauma is to be administered to
the lower subject at 20-minute intervals
until scp-106 responds multiple lure
subjects may be used in the case of
major Containment Breach events
scp-106 will typically enter a dormant
state after finishing with a lower
subject in addition subjects May
this concludes today's lecture
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are and you're all dismissed
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to
big sip
zargaron
oh crop guy
the Morrigan
James sama
braided Peach
that loser
heroin sick
Richard broadhurst
fire of prime
ND versus the world
rubbish bin 69.
Dr Wolf 13.
copster
worthy fire
zazapan
Irish wristwatch
segnore
allatreon
your local Foundation agent
derivative
and Lost Boy
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the volgan
thank you